hey welcome welcome welcome today we're
gonna do some photo shops of our new
true Lord and Savior in the world
there's so much we can do that's great
now really kawaii a chin is so cute
looks great so again I don't know why
but I feel like those cheeks needs to
pop that looks great
please don't kill me that awkward moment
when your face is a fart pillow
kawaii holy [ __ ] nightmares why it looks
great
come on oh the triple chin makes it soak
away
that's a quad chin thank you very much
did not eat a ton of Cheetos just to be
called the triple chin oh my god this is
like a white canvas for an artist for me
Jesus see where that this is turning me
on he looks better it looks better now
than before what the [ __ ] I may not hit
it with a sledgehammer sorry I was gonna
Photoshop him in into a pimp so I
searched to pimp with [ __ ] and this
came up that's added I don't even need
to do anything this is great I don't
know why I think he'd look better
without eyebrows yeah that looks great
yeah oh god it's so creepy
well the Mart is that you let's hope
they don't have YouTube in North Korea
if they do I'm basically [ __ ] is this
Christ I was I've seen it all now
hey what does that ear doing there that
looks so [ __ ] terrifying
what a terrifying masterpiece why thank
you finally someone I can preach eh real
art oh my god a nation spider I don't
know what happened I don't know let's go
back to this one hey let's do something
nice you're gonna look fabulous mate
yeah he's this bald now I didn't think
this one through hey looking good buddy
looks alright
hey potato I demand more potatoes
all hail the potato King all hail mother
of potatoes alright friends that's all
about a time where your handsome friend
did beyblade like me no watching prozis
discarded come birthday and i'll see you
in the next video
Oh double kale goat simulator let's play
it
I can either be demon from Hell or or
demon from Hell I'll go with pork even
thank you
[Music]